veamos en esta ocasión tenemos la
integral de pi / x logaritmo natural de
x diferencial de x ibi acaso esta
integral definida se podrá resolver por
sustitución no lo sé pero vamos a
intentarlo y eso es lo importante
entonces lo primero que se me ocurre es
tomar a como el logaritmo natural de x y
entonces si es igual a logaritmo natural
de x entonces quién es la derivada de la
derivada de v es igual a la derivada del
logaritmo natural de x que si ustedes se
acuerdan es 1 / x de x bueno recuerden
que esto pasa si sólo si la derivada de
v con respecto a x es igual a 1 entre x
esto ya lo habíamos visto y es poner las
cosas en su forma diferencial y bueno
ahora ya tenemos esto entonces lo
primero que se me ocurre hacer antes que
nada es quitar el pin porque quitar el
pi porque es una constante entonces
vamos a sacarla fuera de la integral por
una propiedad que teníamos la integral
step y que bueno está de verde pero creo
que lo mejor le voy a cambiar de color
para no
confundirnos de color y de color magenta
viva por fuera y entonces me queda pi
que multiplica la integral y bueno con
un pincel yo fuera del integral me queda
uno entre logaritmo natural de x lo voy
a poner de esta manera para que se vea
mucho más sencillo que multiplica a 1
entre x diferencial de x y sería muy
bueno que ustedes se dan cuenta que
estas dos expresiones de la integral son
la misma entonces ya que tengo estas dos
expresiones ya podemos empezar a ver
claramente algunos patrones por ejemplo
lo primero que veo es que tengo el
logaritmo natural de x que por cierto yo
lo había llamado ese estado de aquí y
todo esto que tenemos acá de color rojo
esto de acá va a ser la derivada de eeuu
entonces esto lo puedo escribir como pi
que multiplica a la integral de uno
entre logaritmo natural de x pero no
organismo natural de xc su entonces me
queda 1 entre v que multiplica a 1 entre
x diferencial de x que esto era la
diferencia del dv
y bueno resolver esto ya es muy sencillo
ya lo hemos hecho varias veces cuando yo
tengo 1 / v diferencial débil esta col
integral es lo mismo que pi no olvidemos
a pi pi pi que va a multiplicar el
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
quien a pues el valor absoluto de uno
más una constante integración y
recuerden que es el valor absoluto
porque el logaritmo natural no está
definido para números negativos y no hay
que olvidar la constante integración y
ahora sí hay que sustituir aún no hemos
acabado y es igual a logaritmo natural
de x y por lo tanto es lo mismo que
recuerden que tenemos que escribir todo
en términos de x y sustituir el agua
entonces me queda pi que multiplica al
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
eeuu pero quién era o es igual a
logaritmo natural de x por lo tanto
tengo que poner adentro el logaritmo
natural de x más la constante
integración que no hay que olvidar y
bueno si tú creías que lo que
necesitamos pedirle era que fuera
positivo x no solamente eso además de
eso estamos pedirle que el logaritmo
natural
y sea positivo porque estamos tomándonos
el valor absoluto del logaritmo natural
de x y es justo por esa razón que x no
puede ser 0.5 o algo menor o algo por el
estilo por lo tanto ya tenemos aquí por
fin a la solución de esta integral y
espero que te haya servido bastante para
entender la sustitución e intentes cada
vez que veas una integral hacerlo por
cambios de variable esto es muy
importante